all right welcome back to the show the
vegas golden knights open their season
thursday at home against anaheim
it's going to be that empty feeling
though no fans will be inside but the
knights say once they jump out onto that
fortress ice
they know who's on their side kevin
martin has more tonight on the vegas
golden knights
with just four days before the golden
knights open their season the team is
making sure that they're ready to roll
you know we
we challenged the group to ramp up the
intensity
in our scrimmage last night not only are
the scrimmages at t-mobile preparing the
guys for what to expect
on the ice but also off of it as the
arena will be empty
and while it sure isn't what the guys
are used to they can all agree
there's no place like home strange to
say but there
is an energy in that building even uh
you know without the fans and
and obviously there's much more of an
energy with them but the admin
10 was a little bit i guess more quiet
uh not as loud a little bit different
one player in particular who has stood
out in these scrimmages
is defenseman alex petrangelo so far the
newbie has lived up to the hike
he controls all facets of the ice
both in your own end and in the
offensive zone so it was pretty
impressive
to see it firsthand live in a
you know vegas uniform while there will
be many new challenges the team will
face this season
the most prominent will be making sure
they can play we know how important
it is to uh try and do the best we can
to limit exposure
you know with a shortened season with
only uh
you know a certain amount of games we
got to make sure that we try and you
know
limit our exposure as much as possible
kevin martin 8 sports now